December 18th 2015 the quarantine zone
in the middle of Manhattan later known
as the dark zone was abandoned by the
government in the Joint Task Force they
left behind weapons equipment thousands
of civilians and the first wave of
division agents although it has assumed
that the majority of the first wave were
killed the went rogue there are a number
that just simply disappeared what we do
know is that some of them managed to
escape the quarantine zone and make
their way to the outside of Manhattan
Island in this series we're going to
follow these agents and speculate on
what happened to them based on the
psychological profiles and the location
of where their watches and other
information was found
[Music]
you
it would past his parents were Cuban
refugees they first came to the u.s. in
the cargo hold of a fishing boat
settling in California they became
citizens in 1986 after which Edie was
born
fiercely proud of being American he
graduated at the top of his high school
class from here he enlisted and became a
field medic with three tours in Iraq he
received the Purple Heart after the
Humvee heals and was hit by an
improvised explosive device after
recovering he left the service and spent
one year working with Doctors Without
Borders in East Africa we need he
returned to the US he went to work as a
nurse for the Department of Veterans
Affairs he was actively involved in
veterans groups seeking to improve care
for returning soldiers he is neither
love nor respect for bureaucracy and has
been known to reach into his own pockets
to provide for patients when the system
failed to do so
Edie's watch on IDs was found at the top
of the parking building southwest of the
dark zone and the Kips Bay District
caring more for his fellow soldier than
the bureaucrats calling the shots there
is a good chance that Edie was more than
happy to do an errand kinas cause given
how the whole quarantine zone plan
panned out if this was the case as
unknown where he was heading as there
was little of interest to the rogue
agents on the side of Manhattan though
there is a good possibility that he was
being pursued by cleanness as there was
a large number of them patrolling around
the area where his watch was found the
other thing of note is that the parking
building that he took refuge in is a
highly contaminated area he may have
simply succumbed to the virus but based
on the fact that there was a large
number of bodies there and full hazmat
suits I failed this area was the target
of a raid just around the corner from
this location is the Lexington Event
Center headquarters of the ruckus where
the Edward pastor was teamed up with
Erin keener we will simply trying to
find a spot together as bearings as of
no importance to the ruckus anyone they
deemed as official in any way was to be
executed or tortured if they were
unlucky enough to be captured
you
Terry White enlisted at the age of 18 he
served two tours of the Anbar province
and was decorated for bravery after
leaving the service used the GI Bill to
study biochemistry it was highly
regarded by all professors due to his
immense Drive in Abbeville work ethic
Terry suffered from PTSD symptoms which
led to the disillusion of his marriage
he is now enrolled in an experimental
treatment program at Rutgers where early
returns a promising
he has since tried to reconcile with his
ex-wife but so far has been unsuccessful
detail orientated and aggressive he has
little patience for those who Elizabeth
than he Terry has no respect for those
who are unwilling to sacrifice in the
pursuit of goals
Terry's watch an ID was found in the
basement of the building east of the
dark zone in the Murray Hill district
angry with the government for the
inability to stick with the overall plan
behind the quarantine zone
Terry quickly sided with kena and the
other rogue agents his bio chemistry
experience would prove invaluable to
kena and likely assisted in a number of
planned operations including the
kidnapping of the Tali training Co and
the finding of Gordon Amherst lab and
equipment after the JTF in the second
wave agents started the hit on the
United Nation headquarters KYNA saw the
writing on the wall and decided to take
off with the Russian scientist rogue
agents like Terry either escaped with
them were found other ways of removing
themselves from the impending fall of
the last man battalion last seen heading
east as likely that Terry is long gone
from the area he could have moved on to
other operations for Keena
or he could have left New York
altogether meeting up with the other
agents in Washington DC I think it's
very likely that Terry isn't the only
rogue agent that was successful in
escaping New York City in fact there was
another one very close by
Jason Bernards father was working at the
World Trade Center when the events of
9/11 unraveled however his father
survived thanks to the rescue efforts of
an EMT it was this situation alone that
inspired Jason to become an EMT against
his family's wishes
Jason suffers from bouts of anxiety and
depression but through the use of
medication this is kept under control in
high school heals an athlete which was
leading him towards scholarships until
he tore his ACL in a senior year however
he continues to workout diligently and
he also studies the Korean martial art
of Hapkido Jason is extremely
intelligent and thinks quickly on his
feet he is capable of improvising
solutions using whatever is available at
hand and has no problem with
implementation his EMT career has been
distinguished he has always been willing
to take the worst and most dangerous
calls likely due to the fact that he
feels he has to live up to the example
of the woman who saved his father but
Jason focuses on what is left to achieve
not what he has done Jason's watch an ID
was found in a building site to the east
of the dark zone in the Murray Hill
district his profile doesn't fit one
that would turn rogue and betray his
country regardless of how it may have
been sold to him I believe Jason played
the survivor role in this situation and
did exactly what was expected of them in
order to survive his last known location
was in an area completely controlled by
the LMB
it's possible that he was joined into
the lnb ranks as a sign of good faith
from Erin keener
to fulfill his side of the collaboration
between kena and Colonel bliss Jason may
have even been a part of the operation
to kidnap the teletran inko from the
Russian consulate after the collapse of
the LMB
is quietly making his way through the
LMB controlled streets of East Manhattan
with the LMB now fully aware of Tina's
betrayal they have the personal score to
settle with the first wave agents again
for a safety Jason will have followed
fellow first wave agents like Terry
White towards the next objective or to
their planned rendezvous with Erin
keener in Washington DC Jason may yet
become a useful source of intelligence
for our upcoming battle to restore order
to the capital
you
you
Aaron keener was a citadel college
graduate he served at Camp Lemonier in
Djibouti
we're developed a bit of a reputation as
a soldier who avoided combat by
remaining in the base he has combined
his military experience in
decision-making skills to achieve
extensive success in the private sector
Aaron is very adaptable and confident he
always assumes he's going to come out on
top well though he's been divorced twice
he maintains friendly relationships with
both exes
he's been described as too much work to
keep up words by one as he's deeply
invested in doing things right and is
highly competitive Aaron had a
privileged upbringing and has never
really faced real adversity but always
seems to be able to overcome any
obstacle through the combination of
willpower and intelligence as a very
personable character Aaron is easily
able to get others to work together to
achieve his goals well it's no secret
where Aaron key no we're not to do as
the whole story has revolved around him
in one way or another even as we move
towards Washington DC
it appears he will continue to feature
in a big way so with kina we're gonna
walk through the steps he took earlier
on before he turned his back and went
rogue Aaron's watch daddy was found on
the ground and a rooftop bar to the east
of the dark zone in the Midtown East
district but we're gonna take a few
steps back we're gonna start from the
exact moment that kena decided to break
rank and turn his back on the strategic
homeland division and the government
Aaron keener managed to evacuate a large
number of civilians out of the dark zone
and was heading towards a safehouse
unfortunately he was being pursued by
Rikers and he was forced to hold out in
an apartment in the Stuyvesant District
are you listen to me I brought these
people out of the dark zone and we were
followed I tried to hold up in a jtf
safe house but the Reich is out there
game back off if you don't pull us out
these people are all dead it was leavin
Charlie banker in the dead zone as 200
for extraction you'll sit tight and wait
for their instructions until 6:00 hour I
can help
after phoning in for assistance the JTF
officer on the phone said they were on
their own based on the number of Molotov
cocktails being thrown in the window
keno is likely to be one of the only
survivors having to watch the men woman
and children under his protection burn
alive Tokina this was unacceptable and
was one of the defining moments for how
things were going to be moving forward
the next time we see kena is outside of
the police academy talking to another
agent he is expressing his distrust in
the JTF and the government and that
things have changed that now it's all
about power and survival now we all know
what happens in the story after this but
then between this point and the next
time we hear from him aaron kina
disposed of his watch in his ID quite a
distance away the rooftop pile was
possibly the place where keno met up
with his first wave agents loyal to his
cause this could have been the place
where the first of his plans were
organized well maybe he just needed a
couple of drinks to give him the courage
to bite the bullet take matters into his
own hands
whatever the reasons for being there it
was from this moment that aaron keener
became the most hunted man in new york
city and an enemy of the United States
[Music]
these are just my theories and
speculations based off the story
missions and counters Intel and
psychological profiles of the agents
it's entirely possible that they simply
died after being exposed to the virus or
were killed by one of the many hostile
factions there are many many different
possible outcomes but tell me what do
you think happened to these agents
hopefully people actually see this video
I've been having a few issues with
people not being notified there have
been a few requests lately for some of
the better-known stories like April
Kelleher and the noble Scot and what my
take on these are so I'll see what I can
find
otherwise I pretty much have the next
few months videos planned out unless
anything major pops up I should be
covered until at least February March if
you still following the series thank you
for watching as per usual I've been your
host Joe the awkward Kiwi accent Indian
guy Cheers
okay I'll just joking I wouldn't do that
to you even if it's pretty much my life
lately sorry